Is there a kill switch, a way to shut the whole thing down?
Yes.
What really happens is, any engineer can just say,...
..."We're going to disable this for now"...
...or "We're going to deploy this new version of the model."
A human.
Yeah.
The model itself, can it take the place of that human?
Could it become more powerful than that human?
So, in the sci-fi movies, yes.
In our world, in the way we're doing things,...
...this model is sitting on a server.
It waits until someone gives it an input.
But you raise an important point,...
...which is the humans who are in control of the machine right now,...
...also have a huge amount of power.
We do worry a lot about authoritarian governments developing this.
Putin has himself said, "Whoever wins this artificial intelligence race...
...is essentially the controller of humankind."
Do you agree with that?
So, that was a chilling statement, for sure.
What I hope instead is that we successively develop...
...more and more powerful systems that we can all use in different ways...
...that get integrated into our daily lives, into the economy,...
...and become an amplifier of human will,...
...but not this autonomous system, that is...
The single controller, essentially god.
Really don't want that.